do you feel tired when you wake up do
you feel like smashing your alarm clock
to pieces what did you know that you can
sleep less and feel more energized it's
true because your sleep cycle very
cyclically you calculate when you should
wake up all you have to do is graph your
sleep your the cosine function before
you start your venture to more energy
you need to figure out how long your
average sleep cycle is for most people
this is around two hours if you want a
more personalized number all you have to
do is dawn our app sleep time on your
Apple watch this app monitors your
heartbeats throughout tonight and it's
able to determine how often you enter
REM using this information our app will
be able to determine how long your out
of sleep cycle is now you know how long
your sleep cycle is let's get graphic
first we need to define our variables a
B H and K or x-axis will be time and our
Y axis will be o'clock eNOS level from a
scale from 0 to 10 for our purposes for
tracking grogginess throughout the night
RA will be negative 5 and our K value
will be 5 this gives us that 0 to 10
that we are looking for your B value can
be found using your sleep cycle length
which is also the period you need to use
the formula period equals 2 pi divided
by B to find the B value so for our
person his sleep cycle length is 2 hours
which leads to a B value of pi
your H value will be the time that you
go to bed so for our person his bedtime
is nine so his H value is also nine so
as a result John sleep equation will be
negative five cosine pi times X minus
nine one more pin C plus five
finally our tick mark width will be 0.5
because our period divided by four is
half four point five
the first tick mark is also the H value
so for artistic mark it's nine after
that we add point five for every other
tick mark
so it'd be nine point five ten ten point
five and eleven and that would be one
period now that we have all our
information let's start graphing so
here's our graph since our K value is
five or sinusoidal axis is at five and
since our amplitude is five
it goes up five and down five it is a
vertical reflection because of the
negative of 5 which is the a value so it
starts to bottom and then for two tick
marks it goes up and to tick mark this
goes down I'm from Darren it keeps
oscillating forever
John our person wakes up at six which is
nine hours later or 18 on the graph as
we can see John's grogginess level here
is a whopping 10 and this is why he has
been feeling very tired in the morning
and missing many days of work if he
keeps up this sleep cycle he'll continue
to like crap and get fired so what
should John do we want John to wake up
when his cockiness level would be zero
as it can be seen on the graph the
Goggin is level of zero can be seen at
17 and 19 which is 8 and 10 hours of
sleep respectively these hours are 5
o'clock and 7 o'clock however 7 is too
late for John and he would be late to
work still and eventually still get
fired however at 5 o'clock John would
feel great when he wakes up I have more
time in the morning and keep his job as
you can see graphing out your sleep can
make you feel better in the morning so
what are you waiting for take out those
smart watches and download sleep time
you
so to graph tangent we need to first
find a cosine function so the a B H and
K value for tangent and cosine are the
same so a is just a value right before
the function in this case it's ten and
so the a value is three the B value is
the number before X or integer before X
in this very case it's 2 PI over 2 H is
the number after X which is being
subtracted or added in this case it's
negative 4 but whenever you're finding
the H value you take the opposite of
what's in there so what's in there is
negative 4 so the H value would be for
the K value is the last number or the
constant in this case is 3 to find the
periods for cosine period we have the
equation 2 PI over B in this case it'd
be 2 pi divided by PI over 2 but it's
easier if we just do 2 pi divided by 1
times 2 divided by pi after we do all
the math the PI's will end up cancelling
out and we'll be left with 2 times 2
which is 4 so our cosine period is 4 and
and for our tan period we have PI over B
and that turns out to be PI and in this
case again it's pi divided by pi divided
by 2 but it's easier if we do pi divided
by 1 times 2 divided by pi and the pi is
again cancel out and we end up with 2
for the tan period okay so from now on
we find a tick mark with so for both of
them we divide it by 4 so 4 cosine since
the period is 4 4 divided by 4 is 1 and
for tangent the period is 2 2 divided by
4 is 0.5
the first tick mark with is just H value
for both functions so it before for both
of them
from then on we can just add the tick
mark with over and over again cover
second tick mark on for cosine it would
be 5 then 6 then 7 then 8 for tangent we
add 0.5 every time so it would be four
point five then five and five point five
and finally six now that we have all the
information that we need to graph the
two functions let's start graphing so
start off with graphing the tangent
function you want to start by grant
graphing the cosine function so you can
find the asymptotes so to graph the
cosine function you we need to first
think about how the tick mark with this
for cosine and tick mark what is double
that of tangent so for we only put a
cosine point for every two tangent tick
marks as you can see we just keep
ticking oh right there and every single
one after that so the K value is 3 so
sinusoidal axes if it's at 3 the
amplitude is also 3 so it goes up 3 and
down 3 so from 3 it goes to 6 and then
goes to 0 since the a value is positive
it starts from the top and then goes
down and then goes back up so the first
value is at the very top which is 6 and
then goes to the sinusoidal axis bottom
back to sinusoidal axis and the top so
there's a asymptotes for tangent at 5
and 7 because at that point cosine theta
equals 0 in the parent function whenever
in the parent function whenever cosine
hits the sinusoidal axis it equals 0 so
as we can see that's where it hits the
sine sort of axis and what since cosine
theta equals 0
tangent would be undefined this is
because tangent equals sine theta over
cosine theta and since cosine theta is a
zero tangent will be undefined
and as a result there's an asymptote at
5 and at 7 now that we have found
Aylin so we can start graphing tangent
so first tangent is always increasing
because our a value is positive so to
start off graphing in tangent we want to
start in the middle or the same set of
sinusoidal axes so the first point would
be at 4 which is the H value
so we start at 4 and the next point
would be at cosines maximum this is
because tangent is always increasing and
then after that it keeps increasing but
it never hits two asymptotes and then
after that what happens it starts all
that the bottom and it increases again
biggest Angelle is always increasing so
the next tick mark would be at cosinus
minimum then again it would be at the
sinusoidal axis and right there that's
one period but since we want to appears
we keep going the next point will be at
cosines maximum again just like the
beginning and then it keeps that
approaching the asymptotes but never
touches it and again we start back from
the bottom and keep going up and the
next point is that cosines minimum and
finally it goes back to the sinusoidal
axis so let's start graphing this
as you can see this is two periods of
the tangent function
it keeps increase it keeps going on both
sides but since we're only graphing two
periods we cut it off right where we did
so our a value is gonna be to possess
was in front of the function and our
period is gonna be our B value is gonna
be this 3 which is before the X and our
H value is gonna be 5 because even
though there's a negative 5 in here it's
the opposite of that and our K is the
last number which is the constant which
is 3 in this case and our period is
gonna be equal to 2 PI over 3 in this
case because that's the B value
three and then the tick mark width is
just gonna be the period divided by four
or x one in this in this case it's
easier to do x 1/4 just reciprocal and
so that will come out to be 2 PI over 12
or PI over 6 PI over six or PI over 6
the first tick mark is gonna be our H
value and in this case our H value is
five so our first trick amount will be
five and after that each tick mark after
that will add whatever take mark width
and in this case the tick mark with is
PI over six so first we want a common
denominator so we want to do know my
denominator of this to be six so as
normally it's five over one so we
multiply six on top and on bottom
which would make it thirty over six now
we can add PI to that PI over six so the
first tick mark or I mean second tick
mark would be thirty plus PI over six
and if we got an order to PI over six
today it would simply just be 30 plus 2
PI over 6 and after that it would be 30
plus 3 PI and finally 30 plus 4 PI over
on both of these there's an opportunity
to simplify it so here I'd be 15 plus PI
over 3 and then here we can divide
everything by 3 so it'd be 2 root n plus
PI over 2 so finally it would be 30 plus
4 PI over 6 which would then simplify to
5 if we can do it we can give I
everything by 2 actually so I'd be 15
plus 2 PI over 3 now we have all the
values that we need to graph let's start
graphing so graph the cosecant function
we first need to graph the sine function
and to graph the sine function we need
to look at our K value which is 3 and
put it at the sinusoidal axis that's
where our sine function is gonna start
because it's sine starts at the middle
or the sinusoidal axis and to find the
maximum and the minimum of the sine
function we take the amplitude and we
subtract it and we add it to the to the
sinusoidal axis and in this case it'd be
3 plus 2 is 5 and 3 minus 2 is 1 and
then with sine we go up because it's
positive and not negative and then we go
back to the minimum and then or we don't
go back we go to the minimum and then we
go back to the maximum and then back to
the middle finally okay now that we have
the sine function ready to go we have to
draw our asymptotes so as you can see
this asymptotes at all these points
because that's when sine hits the
sinusoidal axis in the parent function
whenever a sign hits a sinusoidal axis
it equals 0
and so since cosecant theta equals 1
over sine theta at that point cosecant
theta would equal undefined and as a
result that's where the asymptotes are
there now that we have that we start
graphing cosecant
so cosecant only touches the maximum and
the minimum of sine so what happens is
first it starts off decreasing it hits
the maximum of sine and it starts
increasing again so it would be like au
next after that on both sides it's
approaching both asymptotes but it never
touches it and then after that on the
bottom it's increasing touches signs
minimum and then goes back to decreasing
so it's like an upside-down u here and
then finally that's one period of
cosecant so we just repeat that same
phenomenon one more time
so that's two periods of our function
[Music]
how do I sound so bad because you're
freaking garbage Hari well what do you
think just like you do then let's try
coughing your sound and see we can do
with that okay what do you even need for
that we need your amplitude and the
frequency of your strings to graph the
song
well my violin was made in 2014 and
violent arm in that time period you
should have frequency of 90 and high
pitches at a maximum displacement from a
four range R of 0 equals 0.38
why do you need to know that man you're
crazy inside the goat alrighty then
let's just start coughing
okay so for the a value we got 0.38
because the maximum amplitude the
maximum displacement of Howie's violin
was 0.38 as he seeded so because of that
you put 0.38 where the a value goes and
for the B value and then we have the
sign there because this is a sine
function and then we draw the
parentheses and then we have this 180 PI
we got from B because we knew that the
frequency was 90 and we plugged that or
we use that 90 in the equation the
absolute value of B divided by 2 pi is
which is the equation for frequency and
then we multiplied the two pi times 90
and got 180 pi is B and then so we put
that in for the for the B value and then
we put that into the equation and then
we got H because Hari
we got H is 5 because harder you didn't
start until 5 seconds later and then in
the equation it would be negative 5
because it's the opposite
so hari's by language tune to hertz
above the normal pitch this K value is 2
which can be see right there and so for
the period we use this equation two pi
divided by the absolute value of B to
get and then we put that one eating pie
we found with the frequency equation and
then we do 2 pi divided by 180 pi cancel
out those PI's we get 2 pi to 2 pi over
180 which simplifies down to 1 divided
by 90 so we put that into the period
table cheat period and then for the tick
mark width we have this 1 divided by 90
and we divide that by 4 or we multiply
it by the reciprocal 1 divided by 4 and
get 1 divided by 360 now we got that we
take the first tick mark which is just H
value the first H value or the H value
is 5 very first tick mark is 5 the color
if you want to confine a common
denominator it would be 1800 over 360
next we just add the tick mark with so
just be 1801 divided by 360
and next one would be 1802 divided by
three-sixty if you simplify it would
become 901 over 180 the next one would
be 1803 over 360 or 601 over 120 and
then finally 1804 over 360 or 451 over
90 now we have our values let's start
graphing so first we want to graph this
function so to graph this function first
we need to know the sinusoidal axes so
sinusoidal axis is the K value the K
value here is 2 so it's tiny chocolate
axis is also 2 amplitude is point to be
8 so you add point three eight and
subtract point three eight and we start
from number five way that's our H value
or it says negative 5 here but we take
the opposite of what's in there negative
5 of or 5 is the same as 1800 over 360
so we started 1803 16 sine functions
start a sinusoidal axis so we start from
there 800 over 360 is a 2 next since
this is a positive a value it increases
first so 1801 all over 360 will be at
the top or the maximum of the function
and 901 and 80 this now goes back down
it comes back down to sinusoidal an axis
and in here it goes all the way down to
the minimum and after that it goes back
it's a second set of axes that's one
period after that this whole thing
repeats so again it goes to maximum the
sinusoidal
axis the minimum and back to sinusoidal
axis
so let's connect the dots
it keeps going on both sides
so we have the first question here asks
what is Hardy's pitch at 6:01 divided by
120 and so if we look at this graph that
we made we see that at 6 at 100 by 120
we equalize it look for the Y value and
it's at 1.6 to the minimum point that's
our answer obviously we need to eat it
so that would be Hertz so second
question is at what H values is hari's
pitch at two point three eight as you
can see this happens on multiple times
it happens once every period so what we
do you find the first time that occurs
which is right here and that's 1801 over
360 so we do we you make a function so
this function will always satisfy all
this need so it'd be x equals 1801 which
is when the first time that happens is
just 1801 over 360 this thing happens
once I repaired and we know that the
period is 1 over 90 so you want n times
1 over 90 so that it will account for
all 2.38
so so
it'd be n times 1 over 90 or just n over
90 so that's the answer to the second
one
[Music]
you
okay coming with exactly Hospital
positioning is right here
yes stop stop you stop walking make
sense does your face Pierce been like
that well get that crap out of here I
suppose you don't have the right bearing
our bearing has no balls which means it
has no friction stopping it
that's right no balls our bearing spins
at 100 miles per hour that's right
1.6 miles per second don't believe us
we'll show you
so our bearing spends at eleven ninety
seven radians per second so so our
bearing spends at eleven ninety seven
radians per second just 1197 read for
every second now we want to convert this
to miles per hour
so first of all you want hours so we can
convert to seconds the 60 seconds equals
one minute for one minute and then 60
minutes is one hour
make sure you cancel those units so now
we come to our final destination of one
blank per hour
so now we've got to convert the radiates
and two miles so we know that the radius
one radius one really is 1.5 inches that
cancel those two out and 12 inches is
one foot
and in 5,280 feet is one mile now
everything else cancels except for miles
and hours now all we got to do you see
we got multiplied with all the top
points and then multi all the bottom
ones and divide the top the bottom from
the top that's eleven ninety seven sixty
I'm 60 times 60 times one time divided
by don't have parenthesis 12 times 5280
see as we can see it's one hundred and
two point zero two miles per hour as you
can see our bearing is insanely fast so
what are you waiting for go to Amazon
and fulfill your frigate needs now
[Music]